[Music]
camila cabello is teasing her new song
bom bom with ed sheeran and now fans are
speculating the lyrics are about her
breakup with shawn mendes
camila's been sharing snippets of her
new song all over social media this week
and although she has yet to confirm the
inspiration behind it there are some
convincing clues you said you hated the
ocean but you're surfing now
that's how the song starts and well we
know sean admitted this in late 2020. my
biggest fear is deep water the stitches
singer even tweeted about his fear back
in 2015 while watching the series the
hundred asking what is that thing this
is why i'm scared of deep water
and when it comes to surfing the lost in
japan singer shared photos of himself
shredding waves just days after the
couple announced their split in november
i don't know man i just yeah now here's
another clue i said i love you for life
but i just sold the house
the first part of that lyric reminds us
of this
[Music]
and it turns out the havana singer did
just sell her los angeles home in
december but if you need even more
convincing we were kids at the start i
guess we're grown-ups now
couldn't ever imagine even having doubts
fans of the two know their relationship
goes back to when they were teens i
really think when you know you know and
um she's been one of my best friends
since i was like 15 years old camila and
sean toured together in 2014 when the
songstress was part of fifth harmony
then the following year they released
their hit i know what you did last
summer
the pair sparked romance rumors for
years before officially dating in 2019.
he's the best and i think we're really
supportive of each other and john even
admitted to e.t that they discussed
taking the next step do you talk about
an engagement one day do you talk about
it yeah
absolutely i think when you find your
person you feel and you know that you
found your person but after two years of
dating shamila called it quits in
november and since then the canadian
musician released a breakup track of his
own the title it'll be okay
if you tell me
[Music]
and leading up to the song's release
shawn and camilla proved there's still a
friendship between them he shared a
snippet of the song on instagram and
asked in the caption y'all dig this
camila jumped into the comments writing
you're crazy wildcat it's incredible now
it seems like both shawn and camila's
latest tracks are focused on moving on
and as camilla says in bob
[Music]
[Music]
boom
[Music]